Philip Schofield admits that he lied to
you and to management about his
relationship with this much younger man
but do you think you should have been
more curious about the nature of that
relationship
uh listen I know there's lots of
questions to answer but there is a KC
appointed for an external review and
anything we may say now could be
prejudicial so I'd rather not if that's
all right there's been lots of time once
it's all over to go through
who did what when why
um I'd rather not just an athletes are
you concerned about the review what it
may reveal no we're looking forward to
speaking to the KC
um
she's very very low energy she'll get to
the bottom of the questions to be
answered I'm sure she will find those
answers I mean all I just want to say is
you know I'm working with a fantastic
team of mainly women many mums a lot of
them concerned for their jobs although
we've told them not to be but this is
the 23rd day now of being on the front
page and it's tiring they worked all
through recovered
brilliantly they worked all through this
putting a program out two and a half
hours a day and I just think they just
need a bit of respite now so is there a
toxic culture at the program or has
there been in the past
I think I'm going to read between the
lines I think there's some score has
been settled but thanks very much